alright um word of warning I'm getting
over a cold so I'm really hoping that my
voice lasts the entire thing so I'll try
to keep this short and also full
disclosure um right now I'm a little bit
high on the tussin and it turns out I
just learned this right before coming
here that you're not supposed to mix
cold medicine with whiskey I didn't know
that and but that train has sailed so
we're gonna go make the best of it um
I'm Adam Grossman I work for a tiny
little two-person company called dark
sky we make weather prediction software
we have an iOS app called dark sky we
have a weather api for other developers
and we make more recently a weather
website called forecast forecasts that I
oh if you want to give us heartburn you
can call it for Castillo and it looks
like this on the desktop and on mobile
it looks more like this um that's the
iphone version and we really tried hard
to make the mobile experience feel like
a native app so you save it to your home
screen in fact we require it and that's
a very controversial decision it lives
on your home screen it's got a little
icon it fits in with all the other apps
and um and you launch it and you get
something that looks like a native app
and when you slide between views it's a
nice smooth animation and we've even got
a nice smoothly and the mating radar map
and the reason we did this and I don't
recommend it for all apps but the reason
we did this is because if you want a
weather app on your phone and you've got
your phone you're out and you want to
access the weather the last thing you
want to do right is open your web
browser navigate to some weather website
enter your location and wait for it to
load we just want to launch an app and
get the weather so if we had gone the
more traditional route I think
a lot of people just wouldn't use it so
that's the reason what we did it now a
lot of ink has been spilt on the topic
of mobile web UI performance and you
know the bigger picture question of you
know what's the future of mobile is it
native apps or is it the mobile web and
more recently the question has been why
are mobile web app so crummy compared to
native apps and and they are you know if
you take the average mobile web app and
you compared to the average native app
um it doesn't perform as well and of
course there are always exceptions and
if you do some googling the general
consensus if there is such a thing on
the web is that web apps are slow
because javascript is slow there was a
great article great blog post put out by
a guy named drew crawford and called why
mobile web apps are slow and he did
comparison he showed me Oh benchmarks of
JavaScript versus native code and he
found of course that especially on
mobile javascript is way slower than
native code and his conclusion is that
web apps can't compete with native apps
because they're in javascript and java
script has to compete with on iOS
objective-c which is nice and fast on
android it's generally java um you know
even blackberry presumably Fortran and
all of these are fast and and that's and
javascript is comparatively much slower
and that's why mobile web sup apps are
slow um this is not true web apps are
not slow in crummy because javascript is
slow and the reason is really simple
graphical rendering on the web does not
happen in JavaScript unless you're doing
pixel by pixel graphics in on a canvas
element you're nothing is being drawn by
JavaScript it's all being drawn by the
engine underneath it which has been
heavily optimized in fact on iOS um
graphical rendering is not done in
objective-c
it's most of it at least the heavy
lifting is offloaded onto the GPU in
fact you can prove this to yourself with
a little thought experiment you know
imagine ripping out your GPU the little
chip on your iPhone and being forced to
do everything in objective-c you would
get a really crummy experience so really
when it comes to graphical performance
it's not about JavaScript it's not about
Objective C so brings us back to the
original question why our mobile web
apps so crummy compared to native apps
and to answer this question I think I
have to stop and give you the two rules
for how how to create performant mobile
web apps there's only two rules you need
to know and you only need to know these
two rules and nothing else so you might
want to grab a pen the two rules for
performance mobile web UI number one is
to do stuff that is performance um
number two second rule is avoid stuff
that performs poorly now before I
continue a brief anecdotal interlude um
growing up I played baseball I was on a
little league team and I had a little
league coach that's not him he was much
fatter and it's the wrong sport um and
one day he gathered all of us round and
he said kids I'm gonna tell you the key
to winning any baseball game and of
course our ears perked up and we leaned
in he said the key to winning any
baseball game is to score more runs in
your opponent thanks coach you're a
really bad coach and it turns out he was
a bad coach we lost most of the games
that year um and I know that this rule
seems very similar in spirit to my two
rules for performance mobile web UI um
but they're not they're not the same and
I think there's some interesting things
that we can pull from this if we really
really try um
the first thing to notice is that on the
surface these two rules seem like the
same rule just worded in two different
ways so I can fill up two points on a
slide but really um I think they're
different and one of these rules is much
harder to accomplish than the other rule
and if you're going to ask someone who
is just starting up in web development
which rule was easy and which will was
hard he would say the hard rule is the
first one doing stuff that performs well
finding the techniques that you need
because a lot of stuff you need to learn
and learning is hard and you know you to
learn about CSS transitions and app
Cashin browser compatibility and and all
of that and that's really hard meanwhile
rule number two avoiding stuff that's
easy that's not doing something and not
doing something is really easy and you
can just you know try things and if you
look on your phone and they don't
perform well well you just don't include
it and so that's really easy um but I
think true enlightenment comes from the
realization that the situation is
reversed that in actuality the hard one
is to avoid stuff that performs poorly
and the easy one is to do stuff that
performs well I need my water so I've
been doing web development for a while
doing freelance before started dark sky
and but I never done any big mobile
project like forecast and I didn't know
really where to start I didn't know what
the performance bottlenecks were so um
well what I did was I went to Google and
I asked Google hey Google how do I make
smooth animations and mobile web apps
and Google said hey here's some links
you might like to read and there's a
whole bunch of them and you know the
first thing you learn is that if you're
going to make mobile animations that are
performance you should use CSS
transitions and transforms because their
hardware accelerated in there fast so I
went back to Google and I said tell me
about CSS transforms in transition
and it worked even though i spelled
transitions wrong and and suddenly um in
a weekend I was able to make my
animations fast and performant on my
iPhone so then I went on to the next
thing I asked Google about touch events
and it told me about touch events how to
capture the event when your finger
touches the phone and suddenly my my
smooth animations were interactive you
can interact with him and then I got
excited and I went on and I asked Google
about app cache it is this thing I'd
heard about I always heard that it was
tough and confusing but you ask Google
about it and it gives you the links the
blog posts that you need to know and the
app cache is something that um well it
tells the browser to cache the app so
that next time you go to it you don't
have to pull in all of the HTML and
JavaScript and suddenly your interactive
smooth animations now loads quickly and
finally you want to make it into an app
that you save to your home screen so he
asked Google how do i save mobile apps
to the home screen because that would be
really awesome and it tells you about
meta tags that you can include in your
page it's really easy and when you
include those meta tags they you know
the chrome disappears the the back
button and what have you and you now
have an app that fills the screen and
you also find about meta tags for
specifying icons so in very little work
in about two weekends of googling it's
not tough in two weekends you can have
you know an app that lives on your home
screen has an icon when you launch the
icon you get a nap in full screen and
its performance and it's great and
suddenly the New York Times is asking
you to give presentations and I think
that was the body from someone else
that's not my body um so learning the
techniques that perform well is actually
pretty straightforward it doesn't take
that long especially if you're already a
web developer and we like to think that
web development is difficult um you know
because it's our it's our jobs it's our
livelihoods but in reality the hard part
is all the stuff that happens behind the
scenes all the you know the people that
work on the WebKit team people at Google
and Apple and Mozilla who are making the
tools doing the hard work to give us the
handful of tools to
make mobile apps I perform well so this
is easy and I really think that avoiding
techniques that perform poorly is the
hard part this is a little bit
counterintuitive because introducing
crummy performance on the web is really
an active endeavour the default is good
performance so one of my favorite mobile
websites is Wikipedia and this is one of
the only content heavy sites where i
actually prefer their mobile site over
their desktop site on my on my phone and
it performs beautifully I think the most
complicated thing on this site is an
autocomplete in the search but they
don't try to do anything fancy and
because of that to get great great
performance it scrolls beautifully um
when you click on a subheading that's
collapsed it just appears and um you
know no jittery animations and because
there aren't any animation so really
good performance is the default and when
we when you come across crummy website
it's because someone is actively making
it crummy and that's a very perplexing
thing one example is I was reading a
blog and it had a mobile interface and I
was scrolling through it and you know
vertically and as your apt to do because
your thumb is on a weird swivel I
couldn't scroll perfectly up and down
and I managed to go a little bit
sideways and all of a sudden this red
semicircle appeared and it had this
chunky animated kind of bitty disgusting
loading screen the UI froze up and then
a new blog post loaded and it was
because someone tried to get fancy with
a swiping gesture to load up new blog
posts and it failed miserably and this
is someone who was not heating rule
number two another example is on the
ESPN site I just saw this where you get
a main headline and then you get a 1 sub
story in a more link when you click that
more link it comes up and you get more
articles and when you do that it is this
chunky horrible animation that's a few
frames a second and doing this in a way
that it's smooth takes no extra
work than doing it in a way that's not
smooth and you know this is a major web
site and they've they failed to you know
he'd rule number two there are design
examples of this to any time you see
content that spills over or now that
spills over your content it's someone
who is you know actively incorporated
crummy design my favorite example is
this website you go here and I kind of
exaggerated about by putting it in
landscape but you have browser chrome on
the top and the bottom and then they've
introduced a header and a footer that's
always there fixed positioning and you
know I don't understand the share links
it's as if you know you're gonna get
halfway through the article and you just
can't wait to share it on Twitter so
it's there and again so it's not just
performance in terms of you know making
some went smooth animations it's also
the design too and this is someone
actively making the design worse by
doing this the rest of the site looks
really nice but um but this one aspect
so why do we do it if it's an active
thing seems like it should be really
easy to avoid and it seems to be a
bigger problem on the mobile web than in
native apps and why is that I think this
rule avoid stuff that performs poorly I
think the key difference between native
apps and mobile web apps is that this
rule is really easy to break on the web
and it's really hard to break when you
make native apps so what do I mean by
this um on the web you're given all
sorts of ways to do things and generally
the way that you've learned them when
you're just making static content it's
not the way you should do things when
you're trying to make dynamic animations
that perform well so one example is you
know say you make a static page and you
want to position something absolutely so
you give it a CSS position absolute and
you said it stopping left attributes and
you put it somewhere um and now say you
want to make it dynamic you want to
animate it I think the first thing we
all do is we load up jquery and we
animate to the top and left attributes
in jquery and when you try it
historically that is given really poor
on mobile you should really be using CSS
transitions meanwhile on native apps and
this is especially true in iOS I as far
as native apps go I'm only an iOS
developer so but I imagine this is true
on Android Apple makes it really hard to
do things that perform poorly Apple has
you do UI kit and core animation and
there's all sorts of juicy things you
can do with this and you can't find
anything in there that performs poorly
here if you try to break it and try to
do these things it's really hard to do
that because Apple has it locked down
and they only give you tools that
perform well and one big example of this
is it is possible to make of course iOS
apps that don't perform well and the
biggest way to do this is to do custom
drawing operations and so in in the iOS
world there are things called UI views
and UI views you can think of them as as
divs in the HTML world they're just
generic rectangle containers that you
can put stuff in and you can implement
an optional method on them called draw
rect it's optional you usually don't
want to use it but when you implement it
it turns a uiview into essentially a
canvas element where you can do canvas
drawing to it and actually the syntax is
very similar to the syntax for canvas
drawing presumably because canvas was
originally developed by Apple so apple
care so much about you not using this
that they'll actually put this optional
method when you go into Xcode and you
create a file they'll put this method
here they'll comment it out and in the
comment they tell you not to use it and
I think they're only reason they
actually put this here is so that they
can tell you that it adversely affects
performance and so I think this is um
the biggest difference between the
native world and though the web world is
that it's just it's really hard to break
this rule so where do we go from here
how do we avoid making crummy web apps I
think the biggest thing more so than our
native apps is discipline um we need to
take great care that we
introduce poor performance some things
to watch out for are well the biggest
thing to watch out for and this is
something that I fall for all the time
is falling in love with a bad idea so
maybe you have an idea presumably the
person who made that blog post with it
really awful swiping he fell in love
with the idea of you know swiping to get
back and forth between blog posts um for
me it's been a lot of things I wanted to
implement the thing in forecast for
deleting saved locations where when you
click the delete button the thing jumps
up crinkles up gets thrown away into a
trash bin and fades out and this is you
know it's really seductive to fall in
love with an idea and when you test it
it'll often work because you're testing
in a environment that's not a real world
environment and it turns out when you
actually implement it when it's actually
interacting with other things on the
page sometimes it fails and if you fall
in love with a bad idea sometimes really
hard to let it go and it stays in and
you know sometimes you don't listen when
your friends try to talk you out of it
um and you know they say that idea is no
good for you and that's fine experiment
fool around a little bit we're young um
but don't settle down too easily if it
turns out that the idea turns out to be
no good for you um I don't know why I
used this picture of an example of a
couple that's no good for each other
they look really happy um and you have
one of them to decide to change their
hair before the other um another thing
to avoid is of course designer developer
disconnect and this is true and tends to
be true at larger organizations where
you have a designer designing something
or a team of designers and they hand it
down to developers and time was you
could design something in Photoshop
because websites were static and you
know developers could implement it and
you know sometimes they had to do
disgusting things like chop it up into a
grid of images and use tables but it
worked um but now especially on the
mobile web um websites are dynamic
they're animated it's really hard to
design for that especially in Photoshop
so designers may have these great ideas
for how to do things how to interact
with things and when it comes time to
actually develop them it doesn't work
and i think that very often developers
don't speak up about it and they it
stays in there so i think the way to
avoid this is to really developers take
ownership in any design work and nef
they are working on I don't know any
organization where a developer couldn't
go back to the designers and even back
to management and say this was a great
idea but it turns out when we actually
implemented it doesn't work so there
needs to be this cyclical process of
development another thing to avoid is
one platform press preference I am an
iPhone guy I love my iphone I will never
switch to android I have a bunch of
Android phones and I never use them um I
have a Firefox OS device and I really
want the Firefox OS device to be great
but it's not that great and so I'm
really about iOS and this is to the
severe detriment of for cash because it
works way better on iOS than it does on
Android so this is something to avoid
and this is the less than I need to
learn um but I haven't I can put it in
the slide um the next thing to avoid is
I call Tess Tess blindness and when you
develop an app you're as you progress in
development you're constantly using it
or constantly interacting with it you're
loading on your phone and pretty soon
you learn how to avoid interacting with
it in a way that breaks it you know all
the little hidden gotchas and
subconsciously you avoid it and I do
this all the time I'll do something and
I think it has no bugs and then I'll
hand it to my wife and the very first
thing she does is break it she'll double
tap on things you're not supposed to
double tap on she'll slide when you're
not supposed to slide in and completely
falls apart um and so the way I know
that I'm falling for test blindness is
when I show a new app to someone new on
my phone and instead of handing it to
them I load it up and I show it to them
and I show them how I'm interacting with
it isn't this a great thing and I don't
hand over my
phone and I've seen all the developers
do this too when they're working on
something especially when it's in beta
if you're afraid to hand over your phone
if you try to show people it by you
interacting with it then you're probably
succumbing to test blindness so these
are the things to avoid and there's lots
of other things to avoid but it really
boils down to this the only way that
we're going to compete with native apps
is through unflinching diligence to keep
from Venus out of our apps you know
native app developers have it easy they
got it by default but we have to spend
every waking minute that we're
developing a mobile web app and make
sure that that chrome enos doesn't get
introduced because once it's there it's
really hard to get rid of it thank you
one quick thing I do have one anecdotal
PostScript that has nothing to do with
the mobile web app UI performance um i
was gonna had one slider here where i
was going to talk about how its web
development is so easy that you could
teach my grandmother to do it so here's
my grandmother presumably rocking out
and bbedit listening to five by five
podcasts actually this is not my
grandmother I had to do a google image
search for old ladies on a computer and
there's a lot of images of old ladies on
computers and but one really strange
phenomenon is even more than there are
old ladies on computers there are a
bunch of old ladies smoking cigars
I don't understand this phenomenon it's
all over the web is filled with old
ladies smoking cigars this one's my
favorite it's inexplicable and this this
may be the robitussin talking but I love
that we live in a world where such a
thing as possible thank you